welcome to the show everybody so there's
this guy Tom Styer I don't know if
you've heard of him according to some
reports he's been running for president
since December and he was having a
campaign block party over the weekend a
campaign party that was attended by some
of his most high-profile supporters like
his mom and his cousin and during this
campaign event he announced apparently
that he wants to raise minimum wage just
like every other Democrat but most
Democrats want to raise it to 15 what
he's saying is forget about a meet
measly 15 bucks an hour I'm gonna raise
it to 22 he wants to raise the minimum
wage to 22 dollars an hour if you're
keeping track at home that works out to
about 42 grand a year at a minimum
that's the starting guaranteed minimum
amount you can make for full-time work
now if you're a small business that
can't afford to pay full-time employees
that amount of money well too bad guess
you don't get to have any full-time
employees in that case and if you can't
have a business without employees well
then you don't get a business your
business goes out of business and that's
just the way it is
you see we're gonna make sure that
everybody has a living wage by shutting
down businesses we're gonna make sure
everyone has a living wage by making
sure that lots of people don't have any
wage at all it makes sense when you
think about it actually when you think
about it it doesn't make sense so don't
think about it at all that's the key why
am I talking about the campaign pledges
of a man who will get fewer votes for
the Democratic nomination than I will
well because his plan proves a point not
the point that he wants to make that if
we had a real news media which we don't
but if we did with real journalists all
the Democratic candidates would be asked
if they support stires plan and if not
why not see if they'd say no that's too
much
I don't support that then they're
admitting that you can't just shout
living-wage and demand that employers
pay a certain amount to to their
employees it's not that simple there'd
be admitting that it's not that simple
they don't want to admit that after all
20 to an hour is is a much better living
wage than 15 an hour so if this is just
about making sure people have a living
wage
which is all the Democrats want to talk
about when it comes to things like
minimum wage they want to talk about all
that all the benefits all the good
things they want to do they don't want
to talk about the cost they don't want
to talk about the practical implications
Logistics or any of that this would
force them to talk about that if it's
all about the living wage then they
would have to support Stiers plan but if
there are other practical economic
concerns to take into account here then
they're admitting that there are other
practical economic concerns to take into
account and now we're having the minimum
wage discussion on that playing field
which is on a field they don't want to
be on because if they admit look if you
force employers to pay twenty two an
hour lots of them won't be able to do it
jobs will be lost positions will be
automated if they admit that then the
obvious rejoinder is yes and that will
happen with fifteen an hour and it is
happening so what about that so it
brings the minimum wage discussion into
a realm where the Democrats don't want
it to be which is the realm of reality
but then what if they say okay sure 22
an hour let's do it first of all the
question is why didn't you propose 22 an
hour to begin with what does the Steyr
care about low-wage employees more than
you do second well if we can do 15 nay
22 then why not 25 why not 30 why not 45
why not 50 all the sudden becomes like
an auctioneer thing where you just keep
going up and up and up the price keeps
going up why not
most small businesses are just as able
to do $50 an hour as they are 15 an hour
which is to say not at all they aren't
able at all so why not why not keep
raising it it's all very uncomfortable
for the Democrats it's an uncomfortable
position for them to be in which is why
the media won't put them in that
position by by by asking them the
question but I do appreciate steyr doing
his part anyway speaking of
uncomfortable positions I'm sure you've
heard the Bloomberg audio already but
I'll play it again for you if you
haven't
there's leaked audio of Bloomberg
making the rounds online going massively
viral talking about stop and frisk and
violent crime and all these things and
here's what Bloomberg said yes that's
true why'd you do it the best we're all
environment and the way that we've done
to other kids is run against the wall
Christmas be good and they started a
whole I don't like that I don't like it
cause they don't bring the gun now this
is of course trending on Twitter with
the hashtag Bloomberg is racist and that
is not the kind of hashtag you want to
see as a candidate
there's my searing political insight
that's why that's why I should be a
professional political analyst because
of because of analysis like this you
don't want to have a hashtag calling you
racist as a political candidate that's
that's all I'm saying bold bold
suggestion and Bloomberg has spent a ton
of money cultivating a brand online and
it has now been undone almost completely
in one fell swoop by this is it actually
racist though his Bloomberg really a
racist because of what he said there of
course not of course not
he's saying that violent crime
disproportionately happens in minority
neighborhoods and that's true that's an
accurate statement you could argue that
stop and frisk is is you could argue
against that
you could say it's unconstitutional you
could certainly argue against the
general tone that bloomberg is
displaying there but the basic point
he's making can't be racist if it's
based in statistical realities now he
says 95% I don't know if it's that high
in New York but it's certainly just
disproportionate in terms of the violent
crime and which neighborhoods that
happens in he probably could have gotten
away with with all of this if he just
had not brought up the racial element of
it if he kept it just speaking in
geographic terms then probably it would
have been fine but he said the other
part out loud and that's where the
problem comes from and it's obviously
not gonna fly in the Democratic Party in
2020 and Bloomberg decided to try and
win the Democratic Party Democratic
nomination in 2020 that was his choice
and so here's the thing I'm it's it's
not like I'm gonna go to the mat for him
to defend Bloomberg and defend his honor
no Bloomberg is a wonderful man he's a
wonderful man you you people leave him
alone I'm not gonna do that because I
don't think he is a wonderful man I
think he's an awful person and would be
an awful president I think he's a he's a
megalomaniac billionaire nanny statist
and and I have really nothing good to
say about him however I'm not gonna jump
into the fray and say this is racist
because I don't think it is and I
there's been a lot of conservatives who
are taking part in the Bloomberg is
racist hashtag and have jumped on that
bandwagon and I understand why they're
doing it strategically because they're
trying to take Bloomberg out okay I get
that but in the process of trying to
take out this particular guy who was
never gonna win anyway in the process of
taking him out you're agreeing with the
left that it is racist to talk about the
statistical realities of violent crime
so you're giving up the argument in
order to beat one guy that is not a good
strategy and this has been my my gripe
with a lot of conservatives for a while
now
we're in order to when they get a chance
to just ask or point against somebody
they'll forfeit their entire position
they'll completely agree with the left
in order in order to in order to win
this one little battle here but you're
giving up the the Ghent the the greater
war in order for the sake of of winning
this battle that's that's not a good
strategy so when you give up the
argument for the sake of taking down a
person then fine you've taken down the
person but you've lost the argument and
the thing that separates the left from
the right and and oftentimes the
separation is not always obvious
especially these days but if anything
separates those if these two sides mean
anything it comes down to the arguments
or making different arguments we believe
different things well if you give up the
argument and get rid of the people you
don't like then what happens in the end
is that you've replaced the people you
didn't like with people you do but it's
all leftism
anyway
and I don't think that's a good strategy
so what do we say about about Mike
Bloomberg well I don't think we have to
say anything as I said I don't think we
have to come out
stridently to defend him at all but I
also don't think we agree with the left
on things like this on points where
they're wrong and and we know that there
are
of service that come with trying to win
the Democratic nomination and according
to those terms when audio like this
comes out you're branded or racist and
that's it
Bloomberg played the game and lost he
knew the Friant fine print he knew what
was in it and and that's it and he loses
okay fine
I'm not crying any tears for him all I'm
saying is I'm not gonna come out now for
the sake of getting my shot on Bloomberg
and say oh yeah that's totally racist to
say that kind of stuff
totally totally racist oh I'm so
offended I'm offended by this racism the
problem is especially as a trump
supporter it gets kind of awkward
because if if Trump's they're coming
here they're bringing drugs they're
rapists line you know that he was kicked
off his campaign in 2016 if that line
was not racist and I don't think it was
but if that line wasn't racist then
there's no way this is and I know that
as you know a lot of times when what
comes to trump we've we've gotten used
to this notion that he lived that he
exists in this kind of bubble where he's
immune to everything and so you can have
a double standard with him and it's okay
but I don't think you want to get too
comfortable with that it's not going to
last forever
and it's not hard for people to say if
you come out as a conservative and say
yeah Bloomberg is a racist for this well
it's it's it's not a hard connection for
people to make they're gonna say now
wait a second okay that's racist then
okay let's look at the stuff that Trump
said so now you're saying that's racist
too and your response is oh no that's
different that's totally different how
is it different
it just is I don't know it just is not a
compelling argument all right I'm moving
on we were talking before about about
small businesses speaking of small
businesses it's still early in the year
but if you run a small business you know
2020 is gonna fly by and that's why you
should lose LegalZoom right now to make
sure that you're set up for success over
the past 19 years LegalZoom has helped
more than 2 million Americans start
their businesses by incorporating
forming and NL LLC and more but even
after your business is set up LegalZoom
can still help you out with a lot more
things like lease agreements changing
tax laws reviewing contracts all that
plays a part in running your own
business these are precisely the kinds
of costly hurdles I could take time away
from growing your business from the
things that you really want to be doing
so don't let that happen
legal zooms network of independent
attorneys and tax professionals can
provide advice to address these things
and more and you'll never get charged by
the hour since Legal Zoom is not a law
firm go to legalzoom.com today and enter
promo code Walsh in the box to check out
for special savings that's legalzoom.com
code Walsh Legal Zoom where life meets
legal okay so we're talking about things
that aren't gonna fly in the modern
Democratic Party here's another example
of such a thing coming from Andrew yang
this time over the weekend yang was at
an event talking about so-called
reproductive justice
so so-called reproductive rights and
this is what he had to say listen I
think we have to get back to the point
where no one is suggesting now we'd be
celebrating an abortion that anymore
in the pregnancy that there was a time
in democratic circles where we used to
talk about it being something that like
you don't like to see but that should be
within the freedoms of the woman and the
mother to decide and so to me I think
there is a really important tone to set
on this where you don't just say like
we're an absolutist about it though I
have to say I am relatively absolutist
on this like I think that it should be
totally up to the woman and her doctor'
the state should not be intervening all
the way through pregnancy but it's a
tragedy to me if someone decides that
they don't want to have a child and
they're on the fence that maybe at some
point later I mean it's a very very
difficult personal decision and it
should be something that we're very very
sensitive to I think that celebrating
children family like these are universal
human values and if we manage to lead on
that and then say but we also stand for
women's reproductive rights I believe we
can bring Americans closer together on a
really really important personal issue
yang is unsurprisingly getting a lot of
grief for that from the left and the
response from the left is is seems to be
there are two responses as always when
this kind of thing is brought up one is
to say nobody celebrates abortion what
are you talking about that's crazy
saying we shouldn't celebrate a board
nobody does so this is this is a right
wing talking point that you're engaging
in nobody celebrates it that's one
strategy the other strategy is to say we
yes we should celebrate it yeah this is
horrible for you to say we shouldn't
celebrate of course we should celebrate
it and so if you go on on Twitter where
this video is this clip has gone viral
it's it's pretty funny actually in a
very irritating sort of way to look at
the comment thread under the video clip
because it's kind of this rotating it
rotates between us you're talking about
where you have one person saying no
one's celebrating it and then right
below them you have someone saying yes
we should celebrate it the left can't
get their talking point straight when it
comes to abortion and they don't they
feel like they don't need to because
it's not really about making a rational
argument it's all about emotion and in
and deception so it's not about being
reasonable rational consistent that
doesn't matter of course the reality is
that people do celebrate abortion that's
what they shout your abortion hashtag is
all about it's about people celebrating
it but there was a time as yang points
out there was a time when the the motto
on the left with respect to abortion was
safe legal and rare safe legal rare well
they still talk about the the mythical
safe abortion which doesn't exist
because there's no such thing as a as a
safe abort in every abortion at least
one person is killed and the other
person the mother is damaged sometimes
physically in obvious ways oftentimes
physically but every time emotionally
psychologically even if she doesn't
experience that damage or realize it or
she's able to suppress it for a time so
but they still say we need a safe
abortion they still obviously want
abortions to be legal they want all
abortions to be legal but the rare part
you don't hear that anymore now if if
the leftist who say that well we never
celebrate abortion if they're right that
it isn't celebrated then why don't you
hear most Democrats or most abortion
advocates on the national stage why
don't they talk about rare abortions
reducing the number of they don't talk
about it and the reason is that they're
saying this is nothing to be ashamed of
this is something to celebrate this is
an expression of a woman's autonomy this
is an expression of a woman's power over
her own body in her own life in her own
reproduction and so should there be
fewer abortions no if anything there
should be more abortions it should
happen more often because it is this
this this this glorious beautiful
expression
of this woman of a woman's liberty and
freedom that's the attitude now
so Andrew yang is discovering and it
always shocks me when Democrats when you
see Democrats learn this like they
didn't know what already especially when
it's a Democrat running for the
Democratic nomination but he's just now
learning that this kind this this
attempt to be somewhat reasonable as a
pro-abortion person which isn't really
possible because the pro-abortion
position is inherently unreasonable but
he's trying to inject a little bit of
reason and sanity into it even as he
advocates for killing babies legally he
so he wants to do that but he also wants
to say okay guys all right fine I'm with
you on that but let's let's not take it
too far now he's trying to do that and
what he's discovering is that doesn't
work anymore it may have worked back in
the 90s okay but times have changed and
it just doesn't fly
that's what Andrew yang is discovering
all right
before we move on a quick word from zip
recruiter yeah I hear from employers all
the time it's hard to hire people you
know it's difficult well hiring people I
guess is easy in itself but hiring the
right person how do you do that
that's difficult you have to find the
qualified applicants you have to go
through the process take all the time
sift through all of the applicants all
the options it's very tough but zip
recruiter makes it easy you know a
codable founder Gretchen he burner
experienced how challenging hiring can
be after unsuccessfully searching for a
new game artist to grow with their
education tech company but then she
switched to zip recruiter and saw an
immediate difference and you can too by
signing up for free at zip recruiter
dot-com slash Walsh zip recruiter
doesn't depend on candidates finding you
it finds them for you that's the point
and by using zip recruiters screening
questions to filter candidates Gretchen
found it easier to focus on the best
ones and then from there find the right
one in fact after posting her job on zip
recruiter Gretchen said she was honestly
surprised that she found qualified
applicants so quickly and hired a new
game artist in less than two weeks
she was looking for someone had
difficulty less than two acceptors up
recruiter she found him with the results
like that it's no wonder that four out
of five employers who post on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate within
the first day
zip recruiter the smartest way to hire
çÿ zip recruiter is effective for
businesses of all sizes try zip
recruiter for free and our web address
zip recruiter dot-com slash Walsh that's
zip recruiter dot-com slash Walsh so
Beto Beto Arora if you remember him he
said the other day that this is what he
said though this is the darkest of times
for our country we cannot give in to
despair we must be honest about the
unprecedented threat we face and then do
everything within our power to overcome
it I wanted to mention this because this
kind of rhetoric were in the darkest
times darkest times the worst times it's
never been worse unprecedented this kind
of rhetoric is obviously very common but
I really wish that we could develop some
perspective I understand the inclination
to want to say that we're living in the
worst time ever everything is the worst
that's ever been etc and so forth and no
doubt I've been guilty of that myself on
plenty of occasions and I think that you
can legitimately look at certain
individual facets of modern life and say
and say about that particular thing that
it's unprecedented or for better or
worse you know the Internet is an
example of that certainly nothing like
the Internet has ever existed before and
society has been reshaped around this
technology many volumes could be written
and will be written and some have been
written analyzing the effects that it's
had on us and I think that those effects
in the end proved to be in that negative
and a pretty profound net negative but
that's not the same as saying that
generally speaking these are our darkest
times as a country yeah this is what
people want to do people want to always
be living in the worst times the end
times the the end of all things the
apocalypse is upon
this is an impulse not just among
religious people but against but among
non-religious people too as the climate
doomsayers clearly show people once the
time that they're living in to be the
worst and in fact be the end be the with
with Armageddon around the corner why is
that well I think partly of course
there's a political motivation the the
opposing party always wants things to be
terrible under the president they're
trying to get rid of Republicans do this
- obviously Trump did this you know the
way he described America sometimes under
Obama although things weren't great but
the way he described it made it sound
like a like a like a post-apocalyptic
hellscape like like the road or
something Cormac McCarthy and this is
what so part of its just standard
politics okay fine
but there's an even baser impulse
something underneath that and I think a
lot of it is a simple kind of vanity
where we don't want to look at things
take things into perspective into
historical context and say yeah we're
living in moderately bad times things
have been much worse than this they've
they've also been better but we're sort
of in the middle no one's gonna remember
our struggles really because there's
nothing to write home about it's just
they're not great but a not the worst
nobody wants to think that nobody wants
to think that we could Wheatley that
we're gonna we're gonna get like a C+ on
our suffering report card
we want our plight to be one of deep
earth-shattering importance we want our
experiences to be unprecedented in a bad
way and we can't settle for the aspects
of our experience that actually are
unprecedented we want the whole thing we
want all of it to be unprecedented you
see this on the personal on a personal
level - it's like when you see it even
in really petty ways and I'm sure you've
had the experience before where you're
in a group of people and you happen to
mention just as an aside you say
something like oh man I didn't get any
sleep last night
all right I didn't sleep much less I'm
pretty pretty tired and then what
happens it immediately becomes a contest
to see who has slept the least so the
next person goes to tell me about it I
haven't slept I'm except in two days
someone else I haven't slept since last
Wednesday funny story I haven't slept
since the Carter Administration oh yeah
well I'm a vampire okay I turn into one
back at seventeen eighty three I've been
up every night since then sucking blood
it's pretty exhausting for some people
people have this they can't stomach even
admitting that they get enough sleep
they wanted they get the they sleep
they're so busy they're so stressed
everything is the worst it's so terrible
it's this competitive martyrdom that we
all do it's the weirdest thing and at
the same time we hate suffering we do
everything in our power to avoid it but
we also crave it and we ending it
something sexy in suffering something
enticing we figure it's a personality
enhancer it's a it's a it's a resume
builder and then of course the thing is
you meet someone or you read about
someone who has really suffered I mean
really really suffered been through the
worst sort of thing a person can
experience you read like night or a
man's search for meaning about
concentration camps or you talk to
someone who's lost a child to cancer or
something like that
unimaginable suffering and you see very
quickly that it's it's not what we make
it out to be when we trivet it
trivialize it with our martyrdom act
real suffering is bleak and dreary and
it can break you
it's not true that this idea that by
whatever whatever doesn't kill you makes
you stronger if you suffer you'll come
out stronger at the end of it it's not
true there are people that come out a
lot of most probably most people who
really suffer come out worse in the end
because of it it breaks them it wears
them down they come out as a shell of
themselves real suffering is the kind of
thing that at the end of it you're
probably not going to say it was super
hard but I'm glad I went through it
because I'm a stronger person now
concentration camp survivors aren't
saying that people who lose children
certainly aren't saying
now you do hear this from cancer
survivors themselves sometimes and and
and having advanced stage cancer
obviously qualifies as real serious
suffering some of the worst suffering I
imagine a person can experience
but that I've also I've also heard from
some cancer survivors who say in their
opinion that the way that we talk about
cancer the sort of rosy tint that we put
on it and we say things like he's
fighting he's a fighter he'll he'll
he'll beat cancer he'll kick cancers
butt is wrong I've heard from some
cancer survivors who say that the that
cancer you know they'll they'll point
out the cancer is something that that
happens to you and it's miserable and
it's horrible and it's not necessarily a
matter of fighting and I was actually I
was talking to somebody recently about
this and they were saying this to me and
I thought yeah you know I have always
felt a little bit uncomfortable with
people saying stuff like he beat cancer
you know he he fought it he kicked
cancers butt
because what about the millions of
people who die from it were they weak
were they not fighting hard enough it's
it their fault
in fact we do often put it like that we
say and you read it in the headlines
after a famous person dies of cancer
it'll say so-and-so lost his battle with
cancer putting this oddly oddly
victim-blaming sort of spin on it no he
didn't lose he just he died like we all
will
he wasn't bested on the field of battle
he is mortal and he died because he had
no choice anyway I'd be interested to
know how cancer survivors feel about
this kind of rhetoric because I've heard
different I've heard both sides of it
and I've never been through it myself so
I can't speak to it in any case the
point is that maybe we collectively
in modern culture don't need to win the
suffering Olympics all the time maybe we
can admit
that things generally speaking and as
you know on an individual basis there
certainly are people in this country
that are going through the worst kind of
suffering imaginable but generally as a
culture as a society we can admit that
things aren't nearly as bad as they
could be and they've been a whole lot
worse when people talk about how
divisive our politics are things are so
divisive and hostile and the way people
are to each other this is just so no
dignity anymore
well if these people would open a
history book and skim through it for
three seconds you would see how
completely almost laughably tame things
are in comparison to how they've been
throughout the entire course of human
history leading up to modern times it
wasn't all that long ago when as a
matter of course you would set her to
settle a dispute with someone by
shooting at each other having a duel it
wasn't all that long ago that
politicians would beat each other with
canes in Congress okay these days as a
couple mean tweets are exchanged or some
mean gifts and we say this is this is
unprecedented this lists this last lack
of decorum the country's never seen this
before oh come on it's actually not that
bad at all but we don't want to say that
it has to be the worst it always has to
be worse and I'm not saying we should be
complacent or contend and we shouldn't
try to improve things we should but we
could do it with some perspective is my
point all right um last week I told you
all about this terrific new podcast the
cold war what we saw over the weekend
this podcast reached number one in
history podcast number five on all of
Apple podcasts so you don't have to take
my word for it because there are
hundreds of reviews out right now that
will tell you the same thing go read
them for yourself be sure to check out
the Cold War what we saw not only is it
a very compelling story but it's also an
important reminder of what it's like to
live with no future which is where we
end up if when the far-left takes the
presidency
the gold the Cold War what we saw
captures what it was like to live
through major events like the Berlin
Airlift the Korean War the Cuban Missile
Crisis the space race and the story ties
all of these milestones together to
create this picture of the apocalypse
that never happened the story is so well
told and the setting is so brilliantly
descriptive that as you go through these
events you start to understand the
battle not just for capitalism but for
civilization itself they've released two
episodes of this 12 part series already
so this is a perfect time to catch up
good just go to daily wire.com slash
Cold War and start listening to this
incredibly important story that's daily
wire.com slash Cold War one other thing
I wanted to mention very important I had
been thinking about this dealing with it
internally praying about it and I just
need to talk about it with someone I
have to tell you what what I witnessed I
was on a flight yesterday flying home
last night on a on a prestigious Spirit
Airlines flight and I'm in the exit row
window seat there which I have paid a
$6,000 upcharge for there's a woman
about my age in the aisle see there's
nobody in the middle okay about 30
minutes into the flight she suddenly
gets out of her seat and then she gets
on her knees okay on a plane facing her
seat if you can imagine picture this and
so she's like in praying position and on
her knees facing sea in sort of praying
position which which I would never
begrudge anyone praying especially on a
flight but it did make me a little
nervous it's like the time I was not
long ago I was on a flight and the woman
next to me was clutching a rosary and
and and muttering all throughout the
flight oh Jesus Jesus Jesus Jesus so
Jesus like that and I got a little
nervous because I thought do you know
something I don't know have you had a
premonition or a vision or something
anyway she wasn't praying because she
then rested her head directly on the
seat
on the butt of the seat her head on it
rested and she went to sleep and she
slept like that for an hour
knees on the ground head on the seat on
the seat were literally thousands of
butts okay
thousands upon thousands of butts just
think of all the of all the Vall the the
butts all of the many diverse and often
quite large butts that have been pressed
with a person's entire body weight
against that seat and she's breathing
that in she's inhaling that think of the
excuse me but but fumes that have soaked
into the cushion over the years you
think they ever wash it you think after
you get off the flight think they look
flight attendants come by with Clorox
and and and clean all the season no they
don't they never wash the seats there
are things on planes that are never
washed but just for years the germs
accumulate and there are other things
that are washed sparingly every couple
of months the tray tables friends by the
way the trade tables that you eat on
they rarely wash those things just so
you know so she's got her or her head in
the bud fumes and in the flight
attendants are walking by and you know
never say anything seat belt sign is on
there's turbulence she's in the exit
room on her knees with her head in the
seat flight attendants are walking by
say nothing to her how is that allowed
could I just could I stretch out in the
aisle if I wanted to could I could I get
a like a pillow and a sleeping bag and
just and maybe maybe crack the door open
a smidge just have let's of reason can I
do that
make yourself at home I guess apparently
the inmates are running the asylum and
the asylum is 30,000 feet in the air
going 500 miles an hour that's not
concerning at all is it I was of course
horrified by this but then I also had
this weird cuz this whole flight I was I
was thinking about it and by the way I
also had the distinct urge and I am I am
steadfastly opposed to the thing that
people do online where they take
pictures of strangers
who are doing weird and awkward things
and then post those pictures online to
shame the person I'm steadfastly opposed
to that I have never done it I was very
tempted here to do it because I felt
like there needed to be documentation of
this anthropologists in the future are
going to want to see this and study it
so they can understand our period of
history but I I resisted the urge plus I
also thought that what if I forgot to
take that it was dark on the plane what
if I forgot to take the flash off and
then it would be obvious I took a
picture and you don't want to deal with
that so anyway didn't take a picture but
I'm I had a lot of time to think about
this and I was III was revolted I was
horrified I was confused I was scared
honestly but then I also had this weird
admiration that I felt for this this
person and and there are people in
airports and planes and this is the
worst I've ever seen but it's common
that you see people who seem to have
just given up on life they've given up
on life they've given up on society
they're sprawled out in a terminal you
know sucking their thumbs pajamas on
sleeping hundreds of strangers are
milling about and they're just they're
just camped out you know and this is
weird emotionally stunted behavior but
it's also strangely confident these are
people who have utterly disregarded the
judgements and opinions of the public
they do not care what anybody thinks
so the woman next to me on the plane
with her face and planted in the in the
excuse me but rectal ejections of so
many of thousands of people the
statement she was making to me was I
could not possibly care less what your
opinion of me is it is of no consequence
to me I know that you're gonna judge me
for this I don't care
and though I'm horrified and traumatized
by it I did I did have a strange respect
forward to because she's exactly right I
you know what what I'm sure she knew was
gonna happen was definitely happening I
was judging the hell out of her but what
does it matter and she was comfortable
and she slept so joke's on me I guess
let's go to emails this is email
addresses Matt Walsh show at gmail.com
Matt Walsh show at gmail.com this is
from Tyler says hey Matt loved the show
what's your opinion on the morality of
eating meat or as some people like to
put it killing and devouring innocent
animals most people like myself say that
it's okay to eat meat given that God has
granted us dominion over animals
I believe God created animals for our
work our work-related uses enjoyment and
consumption some people on Twitter will
argue that God gave certain Commandments
in the past that aren't applicable today
so just treating your slaves kindly and
the fact that God specifically told us
not to eat bacon pork they also point
out that some animals are more
emotionally complex than others the pig
for example is just as mentally and
emotionally aware as a dog and yet we
eat pigs but not dogs what would you say
to someone that argues that it is more
morally appropriate to go vegan than to
eat meat thanks again the way I see it
the only system of thought the only
belief system the only worldview that
really provides a foundation for being
for claiming that eating meat is immoral
objectively would be some of the Eastern
religions like Hinduism now it depends
on which Hindu you talk to because there
are different branches of it like there
are Christianity but some Hindus are
vegetarian according to their faith on
the basis that as I understand it you
know there's kind of a life force a life
energy that pervades all
you know man and animal like and so
there's an equality that we have with
them and so it would be wrong for them
for us to kill them I may be wrong in my
explanation of their belief but that but
but that's how I understand it
my point is in the west where
vegetarianism and veganism are gaining
ground there really isn't any available
philosophical justification for it now
if somebody wants to refrain from eating
meat for health reasons or for personal
reasons that that's fine with me I'm
totally fine I have no problem with that
of course and I'm obviously not arguing
that it's we have a moral obligation to
eat meat but the problem is that here in
our country in the West generally most
people are either going to be believers
in the judeo-christian God or they're
going to be basically secular atheist
that's the vast majority that's almost
everybody with it with with some
exceptions judeo-christian people have
no foundation to claim that eating meat
is objectively immoral because as you
point out scripture clearly gives man
dominion over the animals authority to
use them for meat and labor God even
commands that animals be killed
frequently in the Old Testament as
sacrifices now we don't sacrifice
animals anymore but there's nothing in
the older New Testament or in the
development of Christian thought
generally or as far as I understand it
Jewish thought that would lead us to the
conclusion that all meat is suddenly
murder whereas whereas it wasn't before
now obviously Muslims and Jews have
dietary restrictions but that's got
nothing to do with the rights of the
animal far from it that has to do with
the animal not being you know being not
being clean has to do with the animal
being unclean and then there's the
Atheist view and I'm stereotyping here
but I guess that most vegans are
probably atheist or at least a great
number of them are but here it makes
even less sense philosophically because
first of all there's no basis to say
that we are in any way intrinsically
superior to other animals we all evolved
out of the same soup
and there hasn't been anything
additional added to humans to make them
better or superior you know there's no
immortal soul or anything like that
now the fact that we evolved out of the
same soup and we're essentially equal I
suppose is exactly what atheist vegans
would point to as a reason not to eat
animals except that the problem is other
animals eat animals and if we're just
like them intrinsically why should we
hold ourselves to a higher moral
standard or maybe why aren't we holding
them to a higher moral standard how can
we say that it's arbitrarily wrong for
us to do this thing that most other
animals do now you could try to argue
that we have the capacity to rise above
these primitive ways and to do things a
better way but who's to say that this is
a better way better according to whom
seems to me that on on atheism we are
products of evolution nothing more and
the highest good the only purpose really
is to propagate our own species that's
the only thing that other animals are
worried about so why should we be any
different how are we different we're not
different on the Atheist view so I don't
see you know on the atheistic
Darwinistic view this idea that we
should not eat animals who we have the
power to eat and subjugate just as other
animals do it just doesn't make any
sense
it seems to be an entirely subjective
which like I said if you want to argue
that it's not even really an argument if
you're if you're saying subjectively I
don't like it fine great but when you
try to go from there to making an
objective moral argument
well now I need to know what is the
philosophical foundation the basis for
this objective moral claim
theism or judeo-christian I don't think
there is a basis this is from Paul says
as a retired dairy farmer who has
artificially inseminated many thousands
of dairy cows and stolen too many baby
cows from their mothers to count over a
long dairy and career I was mortified
listening to walking phoenixes is that
his real name Oscar speech last night
in my defense can I tell you that I did
what I did in ignorance I had no idea
that my cows were suffering so
appallingly and all this so that I could
sip a lot to each morning and pour milk
all over my cornflakes well actually so
that you could enjoy a latte import milk
over your cornflakes man in my defense
can I tell you that I just didn't
realize what I was doing my cows because
you see every cow I ever stole a calf
from was distressed right up until she
shoved she shoved her nose in the bucket
of grain that I offered her as a trade
for her loved one and every calf I ever
stole from a cow happily adopted me as
its new mother from the first feed I
gave it also because every cow I ever
stole a calf from produced about seven
times as much milk per day as her calf
was capable of consuming anyway I
thought she wouldn't miss the other 45
liters that her baby couldn't use not
fully realizing the anguish I was
causing I relentlessly pursued my
objectives whilst consoling myself that
to the extent that there were that there
may have been any anxiety experienced by
my cows about their loss of babies this
was balanced by the knowledge that I was
allowing you and your friends to enjoy a
latte each morning so meant you are as
much to blame for the suffering of my
cows as I am well not actually well not
you actually because I was an Australian
dairy farmer and I don't think my cow's
milk was finding its way to your
breakfast table necessarily but you know
what I mean funnily enough all the cows
I milked had 14 I found this interesting
because apart from camels cows are the
only mammals with far more teats than
the average number of offspring they
produce and far more ability to produce
milk than their offspring can use
because of this fact I always assumed
that God must have created cows to
produce milk for more than just their
own offspring so I did not feel too
badly about drinking lattes or
milkshakes eating cornflakes ice creams
cheese's or yogurt why putting cream on
my peaches was a luxury I was until last
night still happily enjoying - I will
have to think deeply about Joaquin's
costs concerns and reassess my impact on
my environment in the light of his
heart-rending speech last night and when
I think that I have only touched on but
but
one of his well articulated talking
points in that speech well the mind
simply boggles with renewed
determination to make the world a
happier more equitable cleaner greener
rainbow-colored accepting tolerant
peaceful victimless and secure place for
cows as well as people I undertake to
never again steal a calf from its mother
and to encourage all who cross my path
to consider the feelings of all cows
before they to decide to steal their
calves that brought us here to my eye
that was a work of art well done best
email of all time that was the the
sarcasm dripping like milk over the
cornflakes from every from every
sentence of that email was a thing of
beauty and sir you have inspired me Paul
and I thank you for that and I was I
won't
I want to track from it by rambling
myself so we'll wrap things up here but
before I do I did want to mention that
you know January has been crazy year so
far and the election race hasn't even
started yet hate to say best way to stay
informed on top of all of it as well is
is to become a daily wire member with
20% off your membership this promotion
will be going going away tomorrow so
that's tomorrow you have until tomorrow
so you can join now before it's too late
this is 20% off all daily wire
memberships when using promo code DW
2020 members get our articles ad free
access to all of our live broadcasts and
show library the full three hours of the
Ben Shapiro show select bonus content
access to the mailbag and now Ben
Shapiro's election insight op-eds as
well plus our new all-access tier gets
you into live online Q&A discussions
with me ben shapiro andrew clave and
michael knows by the way they've asked
me to do a Q&A for valentine's day i
have been the one selected they selected
me as the valentine's Q&A guy so that
should be fun but you got to be you got
to be a member so if you have a question
you can get an answer and download the
daily wire app a member exclusive so you
can get push notifications straight to
your phone again if you want 20% off
your membership you have to act now
before it goes away tomorrow that's
promo code DW 2024 20% off
trust me you don't want to miss this and
we will leave it there have a great day
Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover supervising
producer Robert Stirling technical
producer Austin Stephens editor Donovan
Fowler audio mixer Robin Fenderson the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
Alexandria Ocasio Cortez who studied
economics in college and writes economic
policy in Congress can't names the most
prominent economists of the twentieth
century
MSNBC's Katy tur doesn't know how
senators get elected and Joe Biden wants
to ban guns that don't exist the problem
isn't that our alleged elites are
ignorant it's that they know so much
that isn't so we examine the root of
their confusion then Biden collapses in
the polls bloomberg surges and Snoop
Doggy Dogg gets the media to expose
themselves check it out on the Michael
Nolt show
[Music]
you